Thor: Ragnarok is the best Thor movie so far
and coming just months before the Avengers
assemble for Infinity War, the movie includes
a mid-credits teaser plus a second post-credits
scene.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here.
I just saw Thor: Ragnarok and can confirm
the details of two end-credits scenes in the
movie.
Before I get into them, a quick spoiler warning.
I'll avoid discussing the movie's biggest
plot points in this video, but if you want
to avoid any spoilers, you can tap here for
my spoiler-free video with the Thor: Ragnarok
cast at Comic Con.
I'm also starting my Thor: Ragnarok giveaway
on this video.
For your chance to win a cool Marvel Funko
Pop, all you have to do is be a subscriber
to my channel and leave a comment below about
Thor: Ragnarok or Avengers: Infinity War.
The first credits scene in Thor: Ragnarok
arrives just after the end of the animated
credits and features Thor and Loki who've
just left Asgard and are now on a spaceship
headed to Earth, though Loki wonders whether
it's really a good idea for him to return
there given what he did in The Avengers movie.
Thor quips that the God of Thunder is really
popular on Earth and everything will be fine.
But just as Thor says that, an enormous craft
comes into view, completely dwarfing Thor
and Loki's spaceship by comparison.
This ominous moment is teasing the arrival
of Thanos in what is probably one of his Sanctuary
ships.
In the comics, Sanctuary is the name given
to several of Thanos's space arks which he's
used as a base for conducting operations.
As for the MCU, Sanctuary is identified in
Guardians of the Galaxy as Thanos's domain
in space and it also briefly appeared in The
Avengers.
In the Avengers: Infinity War trailer shown
at D23 and Comic Con, there's a moment where
Thor appears floating through space and then
lands on the windshield of the Guardian's
Milano ship.
Which means that the Ragnarok mid-credits
scene is probably setting up for Thanos to
meet Thor and Loki in space.
It looks like Thor is going to get beaten
by Thanos who might even destroy the ship
Thor is on.
And it might also explain why, in the Infinity
War trailer, Loki appears to be offering the
Tesseract, aka the Space Stone, to Thanos.
In Thor Ragnarok, there's a strong hint that
Loki steals the Tesseract for himself meaning
Loki will likely have it on him when they
meet Thanos.
And remember that in The Avengers movie, Loki
had agreed to steal the Tesseract for Thanos
in return for ruling over Earth.
Thanos may well be doubtless be furious at
Loki for his failure so far, so Loki may need
to give up the infinity stone to save himself.
The other Ragnarok post-credits scene is a
humorous one that features the Grandmaster
stumbling out of a container on Sakaar.
As he staggers out, he meets a group of Sakaarans
staring at him.
In Thor: Ragnarok, the Grandmaster is an eccentric
dictator who rules over the planet Sakaar,
where he enslaves gladiators to fight in his
Contest of Champions.
The gladiators eventually rebel against the
Grandmaster, and in this post-credits scene,
the Grandmaster congratulates the Sakaarans
on a successful revolution and pats himself
on the back for helping to make the uprising
such a huge success and declares the rebellion
to be a tie.
Jeff Goldblum delivers some of his great trademark
off-the-wall humour in this scene which also
leaves the door open for him to return in
a future MCU movie.
So, what do you think about the Thor: Ragnarok
end-credit scenes and what they mean for Avengers:
Infinity War?
Let me know in the comments below and don't
forget to subscribe for all my upcoming Thor:
Ragnarok videos plus your chance to win a
Marvel Funko Pop.
Winners will be announced on a future video,
so hit the bell to get notified of all new
videos.
If you enjoyed this, I really appreciate all
your support and you can check out some more
videos you might like right here.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay movie lovers!